welcome to this video which is a
continuation of a blitz match
um against the computer
and this is actually five minutes and
three seconds
yeah I have three seconds increment now
it's not a huge difference
um and then I mostly have it in because
I wanted to reset the score here I mean
I had played a match before against the
computer and
I wanted to start with the zero zero
again and I didn't really see another
option then yeah some somehow changing
the time control maybe there is another
one just um logging out logging in
didn't do the trick
okay but uh I guess three seconds is
still a fam
deal
um
and not not a big big issue
I mean it does not make everything much
longer
okay we have um
Sicilian Russell limo
curiously enough
I was playing C5 not really expecting
the computer to play E4 but it did play
for
this is a fairly close position so I'm
not too
upset about that
the usual way to go for why this to play
for F4 but
computers not done anything like that
and I'll be honest I just want to keep
everything as closed as possible
know the computer is preparing preparing
um G4 probably
that's not good
I mean that's the wrong way to to
describe it it's a good plan but I don't
like that it is employed and can't speak
um
I just really renders Knight P5 very
doubtful
um
maybe on D4 I can play Ed CD and then
then C form
but it looks like it looks uncomfortable
yeah
that's especially specially tricky
that's just just not a good position I
mean it's pure pure chest wise it's bad
and again the computer it's it's
terribly bad
I only hope would be some sort of
end game end game glitch by the machine
wow really why not just taking on C4
okay
wow that's still good for white but
surprising nevertheless
can I do that I can take Knight takes
Queen V6 rupee 6 Knight C4
not not good
okay
yeah as mentioned it's it's still bad I
expected something else but
this is still a totally totally uh
uncomfortable position
and I can only hope from
some some weird transposition by the
computer
that it let's say goes into some Rook
end game that is maybe drawn despite a
pawn down or
yeah this was this sucked anyway a big
time
Okay so
image Knight B5 was terribly timed
really
the C3 move and D4 was really strong I
have I'm left with so many weak pawns
after that that it's close to unplayable
especially Against the Machine
foreign
type of position that's really good news
seven and then E4
okay that's nice King's Indian is
a good thing against this uh against
this computer
okay yeah that's
I have not canceled yet maybe
let's see what what
with this computer
Bishop here G5 takes Knight H5 from that
that will probably be
that it will probably play
what I don't want is uh to to just
simply Castle short
but maybe involve this kind of
super close position is not clear that
the computer is playing well
foreign
Knight F4 I don't want that that's
really clear
not the night near my king bed please
um okay
night night F6 was really weird getting
getting back
could play Bishop G4
why not
get the light squared Bishop
traded
that's not a bad thing
oh that's interesting
that's interesting
Knight f54 I wonder if I should play G4
here it could be a problem due to G5
Knight G6 Knight F4
but tonight F5 D4 is also
not ideal
hmm
yeah I don't have a good feeling about
G4 really like G5 is
can be a problem
okay here I will just on D4 I will
simply take this
takes on the form so
maybe here
how to improve here
Knight to E3 probably not
maybe with some preparation and F4
F4 could be
yeah the problem with this knight move
is it's not I'm never really threatening
to take on F5
I really I'm really not threatening
anything okay
I'll do that
containing some space on the queen side
but maybe I can get the Knight over
to attack to attack a form this would be
really nice
if I could attack this
Knight C2 Knight to D Knight D1 to B2
something like that
foreign
but I cannot at 94 I would take which is
okay
some way to get this I don't think so
yeah maybe
play some more improving moves
Rook F3
I just I've really wouldn't mind a trade
of Rooks I can tell you that
this is C6 coming or anything I don't
think so no
F3
yeah
that's not a bad idea
making
sure that everything's protected here
yeah
here G4 that's really interesting
but there is G5 really no I don't want
that
I could try to shift this over to E3 but
tonight yeah the Knight on aha he's
playing in the computer is playing G5
just like that Bishop E3
G4 Rook F2 I don't
get it yet really that's a big idea
ah okay the idea is that
if I take now
D4 as as weak here of course
so I'll go back to G1
okay now we know the computer place it
okay I must take anyway
what uh I'm a bit
yeah yeah
this may be a C6 coming the right moment
C6 can be
can be a huge problem
hmm
how to do that I'm not so sure maybe
what I want to do is
um yeah exactly if I go here
this may be rookie three though no I
don't I cannot do that I like to trade
Rooks on the file and I think I'll
manage that that's good news
okay
take that
Knight to D3 would be a very nice thing
to get in
very coin over no
Queen E2 and then D3 Maybe
and then Knight D3 yeah that's that's
good
I have a queen E4 this is through
trading Queens isn't it
oh
okay
that's not bad at all
foreign
so how would you do this
I just need to attack the d-pawn with a
knight and I'm winning this thing
but if I move the Knight
I mean if this is not timed right then
it simply will blow up in my face
okay but the computer cannot really do
much
maybe first go here
and then think about how to proceed
Knight E4 here we'll just move it back
I can go here to E4 but
I'm not sure what it is accomplishing
really
yeah I don't I don't see a Way Forward
at the moment
okay Bishop f ah maybe the bishop to F4
can be a problem with going to C1
yeah that could be a problem
Knight to D3 is just some way to get
this piece to D3
I don't see how
all right
check I don't really see a way forward
for both sides at the moment
I cannot really move my knight because
of Rook H2
maybe I should have taken with the F
Pawn but okay
there are limits to what you can see in
in those kind of games
yeah I don't I don't see any way forward
if we would trade Rooks in some way it
it could be
something
I can play Knight G3 though
this is theoretically possible
Knight G3
but where do I go from there I can go to
H5
trying to get the king over
yeah but maybe you can just take it and
give away D4 for an attack on
attack on the a pawn that's maybe
maybe a problem
but they have Rook D3
that's a bit risky with the time okay
so I can actually go there
blocking this
and now maybe I can get the king over
King to D3
not quite quite clear what it is doing
but
can even go here
is there's some way to
get ahead
I can get Rook B1 B4 A4 Maybe
Maybe
um
uh I hope I didn't didn't do anything
totally crazy yeah look The Rook on A4
is just terribly placed
no no I can't believe this nonsense
ah shoot
now this the computer is invading here
it's getting tricky and probably I'm bad
here
a bit shape
probably
yeah
not sure the Knight is so clumsy here in
this position
great welcome to computer chess D3
uh yeah
yeah this was too ambitious but I didn't
see I didn't see the Rook coming to E8
really didn't this was uh this was the
problem
okay
see yeah all the king's Indian is not
bad if I get it
against the computer it's somehow
because of this um
tendency to to go for close positions
it's quite funny that contrary to normal
sort of games you very often want the
knights and not the Bishops
yeah just to spin this bit of an
annoyance but didn't see how to untangle
Maybe
yeah F4 coming would be really really
uncomfortable
trying to unpin with Knight H5 Bishop F6
okay
yeah well this is this is it is fairly
closed and it is fairly solid but it's
also fairly passive I have no no active
play whatsoever
I have um how to how to allow H5
maybe I can go here and take
sometimes wow really
Knight takes looks
this is nice for me even in my tanks
that's a weird weird decision
my tanks
and then going here it looks
really strange I will maybe the queen
protects it okay
oh where does Rook D7 Maybe
look that's the pro problem it's again
it completely completely unhuman tactic
Rook D7
I have no move now funny
I am
talk about talk about
terrible
oh
yeah
F7 is hanging uh or this one
nah this um running so good
just take take with the Knight
yeah it's just it's tactics all the way
okay come on give me one of those
totally close King's Indians again
this would be really really nice
like D6 now and G6
yeah that's actually a fairly valid
opening the two knights Tango or Black
Knights Tango
an opening that I have played myself
quite a number of times
I hear the key the computer can go to
ear to D4 with the Knight
so I screwed up the move order somewhat
uh not sure how what exactly I did wrong
it's not um It's not nothing terrible
happen but
especially if why this content with the
draw that's that's no no big deal I can
I can play exactly what I'm doing now
and it's uh it's totally equal
Okay so
just
King D2 and play this end game
night to E4 is the freeing move or the
the equalizing move whatever
and we will probably trade lots of stuff
I'm still I don't I don't mind this end
game against this computer sometimes
let's do this some funny things
okay
hmm it looks a bit long it looks a bit
uh
a bit lame to exchange now and rookie
one but
it's it's following this important keep
it simple rule so I'm doing that
Knight to F4 really
it's not helping you so much
at least I don't see it I mean this is
okay
well now G3
I'm not sure about G3 really
okay the computer it might it might go
to E5 so
I don't have four is basically doing
nothing so I'm going to deform
so G3
this is in any way helpful I don't know
before or is it exchanging A5 which is a
weakness
in a way
I wonder about the Knight here the
Knight on C3 is there some
some good spot for it I could go to E3
maybe to E3
like this
don't want to overlook some
some foolish tactic here
like you know some check and then I'm
suddenly checkmated in the middle of the
board
this would be uh would be awesome
if I go King E4 and then it is going to
play H4 okay well this was the idea all
along so let's do that
and if I go Knight C4 now there will be
Bishop B5
oh great
yeah I wonder if there is any way to to
do something I mean it's not like I'm
better even but uh
still you you try to to do to do things
Knight to E4 would be neither nice
actually
maybe can this in
in interesting I wonder about C6 now
okay or you can get the Knight to E6 so
that's that's not
that's not good
Knight E4 is
wow that's a very tricky decision
I have on paper the the worst the the
bad Bishop but
I'm not so sure because I have a G3
coming
it could be a case where
it's not really a bad Bishop okay it's
it's not easy Knight to B5 Maybe
also move
trying with trying this
my computer has offered a draw
hmm
C6 interesting
I take him
if I go B5 here in this position B5
it's probably probably a draw as well
B5 it takes with the pawn I'm a bit
worried
I don't have any time
this didn't really feel like the best
the best possible
outcome but
I needed to to play
okay
well this is now really drawish I mean I
declined the draw earlier but
without any particular reason really it
there was nothing going on
um okay
I still need to be slightly
slightly cautious
I'm somewhat passive here and
it could blunder stuff
G3 here maybe get
get stuff exchanged
hmm
not sure if it was a good idea really
but
too late now
foreign
like
it's uncomfortable As It Gets
I'm gonna go here and go to G4 I don't
know I cannot do this in 10 seconds
uh this this is the drill I think
um maybe uh maybe maybe the computer can
can
um can go to a winning King and pawn and
game at the right moment
Let's uh that's of course possible
I have no no big things to do here I can
just
just Mark time
oh
this I think should be good news
not on not only light Square that's not
a good idea
foreign
no
or not
you can even go to D form
I mean not that uh it's it's it's doing
much good
but uh I mean I felt worse on C1
that much is clear oh the computer can
try to
get this to E2 Maybe
yeah but it shouldn't be any any problem
really
if I threatened Bishop D7 here okay
move 93 hours that's not terribly uh
terribly exciting
and um
wow
yeah the computer offered the drawing
I wonder
is it crazy to think of a win here
not sure I don't I mean I'm I'm
certainly not not
um
worse than me form
I can I can just as well look at this a
moment
I came Bishop
Bishop C8
oh yeah that's that's the problem all
the time is
counter attacking them
maybe maybe if I threaten if I go here
and
as as somehow managed to
um so three seconds
three seconds
I need some increment time I
okay
well
okay okay so I got a drawers
a good a good step a good step forward
I had tried this earlier and it wasn't
so bad really
hmm
maybe I should have gone to D7 after all
this
D5 D5 was not looking too nice
foreign
the problem is that I'm playing against
the computer not the human against the
human I thought well I would think that
there might
might be it might be some play but
it's trick is we will just take it I am
um
and I do this to be to B6
A4 stupid Eminem knew that the computer
would take the pawn
so why do I play it even
just to prove to myself that this thing
will take every piece of material that
can get unless it sees a major
ah well this is really bad um
foreign
I actually thought it I would be worse
than that I mean
not like I'm I'm terribly excited about
my chances but
95 coming wow
and there is absolutely nothing here
come on
let's save some time
this was already Knight C6 was useless
in in the opening
running into D4 D5 that's not not a good
idea at all
play E5 so that I can directly exchange
coins this would be really really nice
maybe I can do that takes takes and this
this type of this end game
is this I'm not sure what this is I mean
maybe this is even a theoretical
position
low here in terms of development this is
um
an issue but other than that I like it
and I can play F6 um
computer can play F6
Knight E3 there is Knight F4 hmm
okay
so not not really great what I managed
to get him
not at all
I'm going to E3 this bishop C5 okay
my 93 is also just Knight E3 okay
sorry for the
for the morning but this is just
completely useless against the computer
come on
uh yeah that's too bad you cannot I mean
a queen trade is nice but you shouldn't
take every possible Queen trade that
comes along your way
this was just uh just nonsense
okay well at least this is a very very
slow
type of position that's that's not bad
yeah the font capture is often a good
idea here
it increases them
control in the center
foreign
some stuff is traded
that's nice
I'm ahead on the clock against the
computer this is a good thing
no idea
yeah it looks um it looks rather rather
equal
not really much going on
I might manage to get my own Queen
trapped this is a possibility
between if I have
no I'm not really I can do that
so this is not bad I mean I'm focusing
this this is a weakness
focusing this no I'm fixing this as a
weakness
but um I don't really see how to
yeah I cannot really get ahead I need to
switch those pieces
The Rook must be on B3 and the queen
behind it this is much better
quite sure what this is the g-pawn stuff
so I mean it's not bad in a way but I
don't I don't really see how it is
helping
okay so we got got to a queen end game
and um what exactly is this can I
play
B65
is it entirely
possible to do anything I can play B6
and if the queen to B5 if possibly
and I could could get the king over
various ideas here
and H5 this is maybe an idea
get rid of the H Pawn weakness
okay
is there some way to to do anything in
this position
C5 or B5 B4 Maybe
maybe B5
still Queen D2 and not not really
apparent what it is doing
okay I'll go C5 maybe this is a bit
risky but I think I can just stay put
and I'm okay but
it's not really why you're watching this
for C4 is not
bed at all if I go D4 now
but
not not really clear how to
how to get anything
uh-huh okay
so I could
take him
for what it's worth
Queen takes
Queen C4 King D2
hmm takes takes
for King E2
Kingo King C5
all right there's no way forward really
I don't see it at least
I don't see a way to to get something
they can really you can just uh
go for the queen trade
five
I can't do that it's it's not a problem
but
I'm not winning takes takes it's it's
not leading to anything
if I go here takes takes
King C2 G4
t e takes
that it should be okay
hmm
I don't see anything else probably need
to take the Drone
yeah it offers the draw yeah there is no
absolutely no nothing to do
okay
let's see let's see
wow this this line yeah this had this
the computer had tried before
and with quite some success I didn't
really uh
do anything great against that I can I
remember this the game
or I'm not sure of the game but I
remember that I didn't uh
fare too well against that
oh that's tricky really isn't this very
weak only form
okay
so the computer will probably play
if I go to H4 something it will probably
play three so I cannot I cannot allow
that
I came
setting up this
this pin
is there B5 Maybe
Maybe
so G3 and uh
G3
B5 Bishop G2 takes and I cannot believe
in B5 I mean the computer must
or G5 is also not something that
I
immediately would think as being great
but
okay
I can take E4 now I can let him take
okay let's consider this
Queen I can
I don't want to let him take here really
I mean even B3 has a move
that's a move that would be excellent
against the human player but
again the computer hmm
always tend to be a
extra cautious
if I just play Queen to C1 and cover
that
is it bad I mean I'm just covering this
I'm playing Rook B1
and saying I'm I'm covering everything
and at the end
I will take your E4 Pawn
like G4 short castles and take it
and now Bishop E4 coming yeah that
that's
very nice for me but the
what should I take with the Knight
actually with the Knight is better even
right
this um
keep stuff on the board and B4
can I play before now I'm not sure I'd
rather play the bishop over to C3
ship C3 now
Queen C4 Bishop G7 wins the house so
yeah I can do that
okay takes
I'd like to get in
Knight G3 if possible
that's also
form well probably just move it away
foreign
that's that's not so great really
um
in our computer will play Rook H4
Queen G3 Rook H4 that's not great
okay
can I get the Queens off somehow
unbelievable I guess bought this this
again yeah this is total ruin over
position for black
hmm they're really tricky Against the
Machine
foreign
I don't see how I can
trade queens or in any case make
Headway
E4 E5 would be nice but
well uh come on I need to
do something maybe Rook F2 is working I
don't know
okay just uh piles up on this Pawn
I take it
yeah that's nothing really
G3 is always attacked
so
very helpful
nope it just takes it
okay
Knight to B6
hmm
yeah that's um
not exactly great news Knight 2 B6
attacking the C4 weakness
yeah I see no response that's my problem
I'm not even a playable move I see
Bishop D3
ah come on this this is disappointing
I mean like this was totally lost
totally lost for black
but it got this counter play
friggin
I mean maybe I should have taken a bit
longer here maybe
tried to completely kill this off
but I was on 14 seconds
um
tricky
yeah well here
maybe not not castling I mean this is
maybe the easiest thing to do
but um hard to tell
the computers playing lots of this
um Queen Pawn
um twins Pawn openings
just
just stay solid
night is misplaced on C3
my idea is to play C5 B6 Bishop B7
completing
by development and having some influence
on the center
it should be quite okay here
maybe I get in B5 yeah I get in B5
yeah it's a very
Artful maneuvering Bishop person
doing some sort of
circle-like movement
it didn't do anything good but it also
didn't hurt much
trying to be quick here
should I do that G6 maybe a G6 Bishop G7
that's not too bad
getting the bishop on the long diagonal
I can also just take here
and now I'll take really if you triple
on this Pawn on D4 to protect your own
Pawn then I'll take it
okay
um
right to C4 4 maybe
looks like a valid plane
okay
oh my Bishop on B7 is uh
suddenly coming to life
okay
if it if it appears on e4 I would be
like to be able to take that really
should I just take him
not a good idea
huh
it's probably no I know then this is
hanging on B5
I shouldn't have played A5 really
and that's surprisingly uncomfortable
ah what the what the heck
did really see a good move here
trying to take play Queen E5 and that's
just not good
B4 Knight E4 also looks terrible
I don't see a move I'm sorry I don't see
a move
I can give us a check first and I'll
check first wasn't so wasn't so terrible
you know here
Knight to C5
Bishop D5 at least
and I mean I can
I can think of nicer things than this
position but
Maybe
maybe it's too Cleo
taking here
Queen to C7
I really want to get the Queens off
okay this this was working getting the
queen Zone
um now
still it's a bit a bit annoying
take some squares on the king side Maybe
H5 and send stuff at some point
here and Rook A8
would be very helpful
um
night no 96 is not threatened
I can do that right can I not just
okay
and if I go
no
if I take it
Knight E6 is still it's still on in this
position it's not
it can happen
probably should go out of this
and now C3 hmm
uh probably not
okay maybe I can exchange some stuff
here
okay
and uh
Knight here to E5 yeah this this might
be an idea
Knight d725
I go Bishop C6 C3
can I no I cannot see three
maybe C3
and moving then the bishop to a tech D4
but King E3 yeah there is no
no real way to continue after that
exchanging the Rooks is probably
yeah looks looks bad in a way
okay
take those squares
and
rookie eight is another move I want to
do no
that's not looking much better but
okay there's okay like play B3 that's
not
it's not the end of the world
okay
E6
and should be avoided
maybe here
I'm not sure about this position I mean
it is passive and everything but am I
lost I don't know
I might blunder stuff but
I'm not I'm not totally convinced that
the position itself is lost
or
so much worse that I should lose
one very tricky thing in this position
is of course that the computer has a
knight that is always
a slight problem with uh
yeah you know the forks
Knight G3 might be an issue
foreign
King F7 the bloody Fork
no
oh no
ah
yeah exactly this kind of stuff costs
you the game I don't think it was lost
otherwise I really don't think so
maybe I don't know maybe it was lost
like hard to tell but
this is very typical you feel
you fall um against this kind of
uh Stupid tactic
yeah okay
one hour 10 minutes in this video and I
haven't got a winning
oh
tough
really really tough
for Stuff
very very solid stuff
foreign
in really
yeah that's not particularly great for
white I know but
it has one
distinct
Advantage it's uh very close this
position
maybe I can
do something in this in this long
maneuvering
yeah whatever you might say about the
computer it's not playing passively here
and not bad really hmm
I don't really have a great idea here
foreign
okay I'll get it back I mean with Bishop
F4 and Knight H4 so I'll do that
three I'm just
lock Around the Clock nothing
too fancy yeah
yeah
this of course I wanted to avoid I
wanted to play against this weakness and
now we can play at age four or what
I don't get it really Rook G2
what is the point I don't see it
F3 I can I can play H5 even I don't
understand Bishop A3 or okay
now G3 Rook H4 okay
so I need to advance
at this bloody
Bishop A3 really
no come on
really
H4 and this was the idea of this or what
yeah F3 really this is working
F3 Bishop Bishop B2
attending Rook A1 checkmate
two
am I lost or what I don't I don't
understand anything here
if I go F3 this bishop B2 yeah really
it seems to work
crazy
it just took A3 and went back
okay
one still I cannot allow it
yeah this is why playing against
computers is sometimes really terribly
frustrating
it's uh it just feels like there are
tactics popping up randomly and you
don't really
I mean it's it's just like out of
nothing
this game looked like black was was just
playing a total nonsense H4 and so on
and it's all technically uh fitting
together
it's um the the big the big problem with
facing the computer
um
V3
it has got this beef this is this is
can I go before maybe I know we can take
on personal but
The Rook end game actually I mean it's
still very bad but I I'm not sure if I'm
losing directly
maybe I can get get to the weak Pawns
okay I can go to C3 but I will get
both B Pawns
uh wait F4 I must address that
um how exactly
Rook B6
F4 takes
no
Rook here it's not working
I don't really want to oh move the king
back
this would uh be really really
not helping
okay probably let's check
wow
just playing for F4 tactics yeah Rook B6
check King G5 takes and D4
okay you can still fight I mean The Rook
end game you can always fight
at least to some extent
okay
um if I go here
I'm I'm probably in zuk Swang right
but not sure
and rock me through it bloody tactics
yeah it's it's always it's always those
kind of one or two move tricks yeah that
you can overlook takes Rook B3
okay then it means that it was it was a
complete swung right it couldn't move
the look somewhere else
King on the second rank is the Czech
King on the fourth rank Rook B4 check
and if I can just show it Rook B3 and
that's it
yeah very nice
very nice 10 games 1 hour 20 minutes hmm
oh I'll do one or two more
I really want to win one
and I had one or two totally winning
ones which I didn't didn't convert
I really need some good anti-computer
idea against this
maybe maybe D5 E5 this kind of stuff my
computer okay so I go for this love
exchange it's maybe not so bad
at least it's um it's leading to totally
symmetrical stuff quickly
wow
no I've never seen this move
um
not sure if this was a successful idea
Knight A5 but okay you need to
play some moves
five
okay let's just
play quickly
okay it's not clear what the Knight on
A5 is doing anyway
okay
if you insist I play it again
okay how do I get
the night away from me five maybe like
that 97 coming
now that's um
Queen F3 is good
surprisingly human approach
by the computer
almost like it it was a new thing that
were wow
okay
yeah it's unfortunately
um unfortunately really working
but um maybe okay I can take here
I mean it's not like great but
it's not like C8 hangs but D3 hangs okay
and again some some bloody tactic
ah
okay
yeah I'm a bit hesitant and I'm not
quite sure what to make out of make of
this
so
so bad maybe just um concretely this was
D5 and stuff
but other than that I'm this is not so
bad
I don't have the coordination here it's
a problem
I like I like the coordination
um and I like tactical Vision at the
moment also wow okay
yeah that's um
this is just a position
um I mean okay black is lost yeah Rook
two three pawns is too much but it's the
type of position where if you play it
against the human
you would get some sort of chance I mean
maybe yeah because you've got this
Knight and you can maybe get something
on the king but this computer will just
defend this and never allow any um any
stupid tactic
we had D5 Rook C7 I can I can I can give
this up
yeah Knight takes D5 was too much and it
really followed up with the toughest
possible continuation all the time
that's really really tough
just these two drawers not not good
okay
maybe I can try the French exchange it's
um
oh wait I had a good french with that
once earlier
played B6 yeah and didn't really play
too well after that
maybe um I can can just uh
play something similar
yeah that's that's very uh very very
similar to what I had before
okay
I'm not sure if I played H6 but
it's not look too bad get some
get some room here
to G4 on where to G3 it does not do much
there
well at least Black's not going to
Castle short I mean
I'm going to predict that he's not
cursoring short
like
allowing all kinds of sacrifices
okay if I take it no probably not
does not help
maybe the computer can play Knight E4
this is
using this bishop
interesting
okay I need to make sure that this is
not happening
this um 94 business
okay and now this one I want
I want to clarify this here on the on
the king side
okay
how do I make sure that
I get the H5
The Rook on H1 how do I get it
there
might be two maybe the Knight over to G3
and Rook to H1 this this could be
a possible setup now he's got
like a computer
wondering about Knight C4 at some point
some sort of trick to get the Knight
into the play
didn't see any I didn't see it really
working
okay so I get the Rook to H1 that's a
good thing
um Queen F1
okay
this is what I was talking about not I
don't want
the night near my king but it already is
there it's not that's not nice
these types of moves I should have
exchanged myself
but uh okay I couldn't really do it
again F3 that's Rook G4
um food
what am I doing now Queen D1
it's already uncomfortable
how did that happen from this good
position
amazing really amazing
maybe I should have played B3 or
something like that I don't I don't know
Queen E2 is this queen h8 yeah and I'm
losing the H far
remarkable
I don't see a move I really I mean a
good one I mean can any CL of course I
can take on C4 or some nonsense like
that but I don't see a good one don't
see a good move
Queen D1 Maybe
um
step by step a computer is activating
his position and
and I don't I don't see anything good
not not exactly a move I wanted to play
yeah
Knight takes Queen G2
Pawn takes yeah it looks like it's not
really
it looks like bad but
yeah there was something I didn't see
exactly what but there was something
obviously
yeah you can the only the only real you
need to be tactically super alert it's
simply
like that I mean this was really a
totally bad position for black but I I
let him out
I let the computer out and um
then it's just happening so quickly
um
any way to fight here
I would have some slight hopes with the
Knight and
Queen combination but G2 is just hanging
I don't
I don't see what to do
I can play G3 but the computer will play
H3 and not take
no it takes okay
maybe this is also valid
why this is so bad
I take a seven
probably
okay
yeah I know I'm I'm materially down but
at least the
at least I'm not
not getting mated and
there are some chances for a blockade
here maybe
and this should be one right
yeah
yeah that much about the blockade
Jim
okay
how did I spoil this I mean this is just
just a very good position here
it's got the bad Bishop I have control
here everything
this is just um just just amazing
the problem is I must trade myself I
just I need to trade here myself and
then continue from there
and he's got these weaknesses and so on
yeah this is what I needed to do
Rook H4 was very strong ah I simply
didn't didn't think about Rook H4
okay so this is what do we have here
game 13 okay this will be the last game
I need to to quit this 90 minutes far
too long really
okay
yeah and this is
this really not great kind of setup is
sometimes played by the machine
weakening the D4 Square
but um
it's still hard to break down of course
weakening the E4 Square did I say D4
Square E4 of course
so take it and play something on D5
yeah I guess
might be six something on D5 wow
foreign
okay I cannot calculate this now but I
want to get the Queens off
yes yeah I saw that but no I want queens
off
yeah maybe
Knight G5
ah
okay let's just
not panic for a moment and uh
think about that
if I go Rook F to d8
Knight G5 and it really is a problem
I can play Knight D5 but computer will
play Knight G5 take F7 I mean just like
that
just um
it's just grabbing stuff
and hoping and not hoping I mean
calculating
that it gets away with it
what happens after F6 I don't understand
it yet but
Rook H4 here
hmm
remarkable
and Rook H6
and sorry Knight H6 IQ Knight H6 trying
to trap this Rook
so bad for me
really
The Rook is trapped okay
okay
I'll take it I'll take it come on
it's still trapped
in a way
Knight cannot move
okay I should use my Rooks both of them
okay
and then make it if I manage to
get this Knight away
Knight F4 Maybe
a computer might take on H6 take on F7
yeah
probably will do that
maybe maybe I can cover
this stuff first
okay
if I go
Knight E3 now Knight E3
looks terribly shaky
you really want to not spoil this
okay
take it then E6 yeah
okay but at least that's that's a purely
technical end game
takes
and King G7 and I'm gonna Mix Change Up
on
okay
this is at least um a clear a clear uh
task at hand win with the extra Exchange
how can I best do that
provoke Rook D5 and stuff provokes some
weaknesses Maybe
yeah this should be the right way to go
it can play um it can play this um
stuff on the king side getting a passer
but
that's not not too dangerous
oh wait B5 this bishop D2
Rook A6
and A5
and that's bloody awful no
let's not do that
not recommended
okay so B5 maybe A6 B5
or A5 B5
not not sure yeah I'm being extra
careful here
thinking briefly about
going
um C5 and Rook D3 but
I'm not sure really
how do I do that
without allowing any sort of any sort of
trickery
foreign
A6 B5 that's A5
okay I need to I need to do something
okay
this is I didn't expect really
now the the air Pawn looks looks very
weak
and I thought that probably the combined
threats against D4 and A4 should
win another Pawn
Rook here
and the g Pawn is I can I can
can stop with my king
okay all this is this is save at the
moment
G6 there is uh King F6
okay just here
foreign
yeah okay it can it can basically the
pawn can go to G7
and then I play King F7 and there's
nothing happening
this is the kind of move that
since some shivers down your spine like
have a blunt at something I don't think
I have
that's funny really I said that this is
the last game and I get the win in
that's great
at least one win
yeah no stalemate please
yeah this didn't look like a win really
at the beginning with this
attack but somehow
the computer I got The Rook to H7 and
there it was trapped yeah
quite funny
wow finally
okay so this is the end of this uh
uh almost what
two hour video okay but I played until I
win 13 games
this wasn't terribly great play by me I
mean at least I got a winning at the end
but I lost quite quite a number of games
where I didn't really got near all right
I hope you liked it and um
you will
switch on again if I do the next match
thanks for watching